okay good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
welcome to this talk on SEPA bus
concepts with developers my name is
Hubert Matthews I'm an independent
consultant and trainer I live in the UK
in Oxford next to the river that's
enough about me I usually start with
this question why this talk so it's
always kind of why make it why am I
talking about this subject one of the
things I found talking to people about
C++ and C plus 20 and I said well what
did you want most out of C++ 20 they
said concepts and I say why oh I think
there's a lot more to two concepts than
just that so this seems to be something
that people want but they're not
entirely sure why they wanted it just
seems like a really good idea and
something they've heard about so what
I'm going to try and do is to frame
concepts going well okay
I'm not just going to do syntax this is
not a tutorial this is about how they
fit in the big picture and why you as
application developers should be
interested in concepts and what you can
do with them so we're gonna have a few
things here so this is a broad talk it's
not a tutorial introduction we will be
looking at code we will be looking at
syntax I will be telling you some about
some of the parts but I'm not going to
go through this is how you actually do
them that's a whole kind of separate
other thing I want to talk about the
history of where these come from because
they're actually not very new how does
this work with other languages other
languages have things a bit like
concepts and how they different so if
you've seen other things in things like
Java and c-sharp what is it the
difference there requires clauses and
other places like that what what are we
doing with types
so there's a whole relationship here
about types and classes and interfaces
and object orientation and there's a
sort of kind of bit of computer science
II stuff going on in here we have to
think about how does this all fit
together with inheritance and other
things and why should you care you know
why do these people these nice people
let's see what essential stick this damn
thing in here was it just to confuse it
or just seemed like a good idea at the
time
what can you do with concepts what can
you not do with concert
and how should you design with them so
that hopefully that's going to give you
an idea of how they are where they are
on a broad scale it's not going to be an
itty-bitty little thing but we're gonna
see some some old things and some bits
and pieces right okay concepts have been
around for a long time
be honest restric mentioned this in his
book designing evolution of C++ in 1994
that's 25 years ago he's been trying to
get our concepts into the language he
got Auto with the auto deduction in
about nine in the 1980s and then he had
to take it out because C programmers
hated it so there's a lot of stuff that
bianna has been trying to get in for a
long time and this is one of those ones
it was aiming to get into C++ 11 what
was called super Abaza 0x at the time
and the point about the on one is he
didn't get in and it didn't get her in
for a number of reasons it was a
language based view rather that and had
things like concept maps and some really
quite complex things it was a it was an
interesting implementation but and the
but was a very big but there was
problems with compilation speed there
was only one compiler that did this the
concept GCC one and that was about ten
times slower than normal compilation
that didn't look good there were other
problems with the technical wording in
the stand of the circle standardise four
concepts was bigger than the rest of
template's put together so this is like
kind of big major change they went she's
really not good and he got withdrawn
from C+ 11 at the Frankfurt meeting so a
little bit in the way that contracts
have just been taken out in C but was 20
it just wasn't ready
people went we got one chance to get
this in when we don't have the
experience we don't feel it's right it
got pulled so it didn't get there right
okay after C for bus 11 there was like
okay what are we going to do about this
one here these concept things that kind
of nice and there is this thing that of
the concept light and then several
things going on here so there was this
technical specification and that's what
GCC for instance is implemented from
version 6 onwards there was a meeting at
Palo Alto organized by stepping off
who the one of the fathers of the STL
and he invited lots of people through
then they went through what are the
concepts in the STL and what were those
things so they went through that one
well we looked with this we here we need
to have this net cetera and that was
kind of the basis of where the concept
TS this is the minimal amount of stuff
we kind of need having gone really big
they went well what we actually need
yeah that was just that was overreach
let's go to something else that's what
they did there and it then became around
requirements not so much around language
for reasons they call C++ because
whatever it didn't make any sequel verse
17 it was shame it's gonna coming to 20
it was one of the first things that went
into the working draft after C+ 17 in 20
so it's in there there are some tweaks
from the Erb the TS but it's going to be
in there so what is it what I'm going to
do one of the things is that based
around that sort of kind of Palo Alto
view and stepping off and other things
they think well actually concepts a math
or math depending where you come from
this is something it's it's a sort of
kind of computer science a view of the
way things are done it's a abstraction
and mathematical concepts it encompasses
syntax and also semantics and
constraints on types etc see but was xx
only does the syntax part by the way you
can't do semantic constraints they're
based around axioms that you can't
represent directly in the language well
okay if a equals equals B then you would
expect that not a not equal B is always
true you can't express that so these are
some of the ideas that you want to get
across in concepts in the sort of kind
of big version of concepts of an idea
but you can't actually express in the
language so we have to think about
syntax semantics and axioms how would
you express that the input to an
algorithm is requires it to be sorted
that's actually quite hard to express
and certainly hard to check because
actually you've got to go and do a lot
of checking and even if I give you to
iterators into two different containers
you how do you tell it's completely you
can't actually check
those things so that's one view it's not
necessarily a view that I think is
particularly helpful for application
developers it's it's one part of the
landscape back to the Sufi elephant you
know with the the leg and that the ear
and the trunk and the tail etc it's one
part of the concepts jigsaw there's
another kind of view which says contacts
are hard they're difficult you shouldn't
try and do your own things application
developers should stay away and there's
this idea that you shouldn't be using
writing your own concepts you should use
the ones in the standard library you
should use regular you should use equity
equality comparable and other things out
of the standard you shouldn't write your
own ones this is quite common amongst
certain members of the community I'm not
gonna point fingers but it's it's one
view that says don't write your own
concepts because they're hard well okay
you look at the core guidelines called
int leaven wherever possible use the
standard concepts okay well that's fine
but what does that imply for application
developers do you know what's there and
is it actually relevant to your domain
this idea that concepts are hard says
well yeah okay that's fine when you're
doing library stuff but if you're an
application developer you're going like
that's not my domain I don't write
libraries so my opinion and it's just an
opinion that concepts offered fantastic
new opportunities to develop us and if
used well so I'm going to try and see if
I can give you a hint of what some of
that might be what can you do with
concepts then if they are such a good
thing what can you not do they are
syntactic constraints on types basically
we've got ten template type name teed
supplying constraints to that we'll see
even more detail coming up there it
allows us to put more domain knowledge
into the application into the language
and get it checked what you might now
have in documentation you can now put
into the language compilers don't read
documentation developers probably don't
read documentation so the answer is how
do we get more checking here how do we
get this one here so you can think of
things like strong
Def's domain concepts so avoiding
passing just raw integers you create
some kind of drain type that represents
something else so instead of passing
just a string you pass a a postal code
or an ISBN or something like that you're
raising the level of what you're talking
about rather than just pure native raw
stuff that's we're kind of trying to do
the same thing here but rather than tea
again I said you can't express axioms so
you can't say that a less than a should
never be true all that if a was less
than B and B is less than C that that
implies a is less than C there are
things you can't do so it's a limited
set but it's a useful limited set you
can also apply this to compile time
values so it's not just type name T you
can actually apply it to int N and other
things like that and template template
parameters which will please some people
a lot a concept as a constraint on a
type it's not a type you can't create a
concept you can't instantiate a concept
it's a set of of constraints on
something it already exists for instance
you can't have vector of concept pointer
because it's not a thing it's a
constraint on something else you can
have vector of object pointer and then
constrain it say well it has to be
vector of concept pointer you can do
that but you can't create things of
concepts directly oops
did we go back one no contracts contract
unfortunately didn't make it into c plus
20 if you consider the concepts of
constraints on types contracts are
essentially then providing some
constraints on runtime values so they
have a very interesting complementary
functionality and for so they would
allow you to provide some of the
semantics if you look in the standard
you'll find it says oh well here are the
types you could do that one and then
you've got some relying some ensures and
requires clauses pre and post conditions
that tell you what things should do what
and it's valid to call when it's
not and those are often much more about
contracts so they are very interesting
pairing unfortunately we only get the
concept part of this one in 20 you'll
see later on how that all do this one
okay
other languages so we're gonna have a
look at C sharp again have a look at
Java what do we got here c-sharp has got
something that looks a bit like this it
says write public class gen T where T
has to be derived from I comparable of T
it's essentially a similar kind of thing
it says well you can only provide me a
tea that meets these conditions and
their syntactic conditions it says well
it has to drive from this interface
that's the kind of thing you might want
to do we see publish contrib concepts
but there's a big difference here
there's a limit on what you can do with
a c-sharp font version so it's you can
drive from this you can use this other
things new enum class truck managed what
about there's only a few things you can
say about this and the reason there's
only a few things you can say about this
because this is actually really a cast
in disguise it says well you can put
that in there and there if you've got
these certain constraints then I'll do a
cast and inside you can treat it in
certain ways because you can go well
okay if this one here's got search NT
like that and inherits from I comparable
I can then call the methods on I
comparable because it's cast it in the
implementation that's very different to
C++ so one of the things about C++
concepts is it is it constrains what you
can put in but there is no constraint at
all on the implementation that's very
deliberate so in C in c-sharp and in
Java if you have a constraint on this
one here what comes in also applies
inside because it's essentially implicit
cast in C++ that's not the same so if
you've seen this before you can kind of
get a flavor there's something similar
but it's not the same Java again you can
say look this thing has to extend number
so there's kind of this exists in other
languages been slightly different ways
other languages because they're
object-oriented and they have an object
right at the top they're essentially
doing some form of type erasure here
right so here's one of my key points
which is that how do you scale generic
programming so if you're programming
with template type name T you go well
okay I've got this third-party library
which says T what goes there I have no
idea I have to kind of chase around for
the documentation if you're using
something in Python for instance you go
yeah it takes a sec some stuff I have to
look at the names I have no idea I can
put anything in there and if I put the
wrong thing in what happens it maybe
falls over at runtime if I happen to
call that particular path so it doesn't
scale well and why did it not scale
because it just says it's anything type
name T and if you've got the more types
you've got there if you've got n types
you go well I basically got N squared
because I go well well how does what
does it what can go here what
combinations are valid what combinations
are not valid and you can't tell just by
looking at type name T if on the other
hand it says a concept it has to have
this requirement you go ok that's tell
me what's going on
maybe my IDE can point me in the
direction of going ah right you can't do
that sorry sorry that's got the wrong
thing it's then essentially
documentation that you've got to read in
the compiler can check it for you that's
one of the key things notice what
happens as languages get bigger as they
get older away they start using more
mature systems is that type less things
start to get tight because of this
problem when C++ where now this this
point JavaScript basically yeah you can
call anything if anything and people
have discovered that's a bit bit
difficult so they've introduced
typescript
typing on untyped things PHP yeah I can
put anything in that wouldn't be nice if
you just put some type traits on here
which just sort of kind of tell you what
it is and you can see this is a general
trend as languages get larger and more
mature and you're trying to do more
stuff Java and c-sharp generics you've
added these where clauses and wildcards
etc because just tea is just too wide
XML I didn't schemas because does that
really valid I don't know oh you can got
some way of checking it so concepts make
generic programming scale
that's one of my one of the points I can
want to make concepts are duck typing if
you've come across this idea in Python
it's probably where it first came from
if something looks like a duck walks
like a duck talks like a duck I'm gonna
treat it like a duck and that's what
templates do anyway which is I don't
care where you come from what you are
what's going on etc do you have the
relevant stuff and that's duck typing
Python does it a run-time
c+ does this at compile time and what
concepts do go well I can now do that
checking at one point rather than the
implementation what's the difference
well if I have an implementation and I
call something about 20 times and you
pass the wrong thing I'm going to get 20
nasty incomprehensible error messages
this is an error novel that just goes on
forever yeah if I have a concept it says
oh sorry you can't put that there you
get one message saying that's wrong and
here's why that's a much nicer approach
we get much clearer interfaces rather
than the all well what should I pass in
for this parameter yes the thing that
you are after that people are asking for
better error messages we hope we're
going to get better error messages
compilers will get better at this but if
you try it you'll find it at least tells
you that can't go here rather than by
the way all these horrible things happen
if you try and it's based on the
interface not on the implementation
currently it's implementation based and
this is an interface thing it allows you
to capture domain knowledge you go well
what does it mean to be one of those
things I can now say what does it mean
to be an stl container okay I can I'm
only gonna take an STL container and you
try to throw something in that's not
quite an SQL container it won't work it
allows for ad hoc and and post facto
combinations that you don't have with
straightforward oo are going to cover
this in a little more detail later this
is an early form really of introspection
it allows you to be able to say look
Kant does this work can we instantiate
it's a form of introspection ongoing
does this work
and it not fall over if you try it's
almost like an NGO here's some code that
wouldn't compile and just tell me
whether it would compile or not that's
kind of a valuable thing other languages
several things like eval that all then
throw yeah Perl try and evaluate this
one nice bang whatever but now we can go
if I do this and this and this is would
that be okay you can't do that now this
is what concepts are going to do and you
can then do it in an ad hoc way as well
so it's a form of introspection the next
step is we're gonna get reflection when
she's being agreed-upon the core model
is there but we haven't got there the
syntax for doing it if you've used
templates and you try to control
overloading of templates using enable if
and spinni and all these other kind of
things you've now got a language based
mechanism rather than a hack so all
those kind of enable things are a bit
hacky they work well at single point
just kind of stuff I want to look at
this one thing but they don't work while
actually I need these seven methods it
really doesn't scale very well to do
that they're built into the language so
you can now get compilers to do pattern
matching for you can say well it matches
this or this or this and there's a
defined order in which things happen so
you can write your stuff yeah if it's
this case do this this deal and you
don't have to kind of do all this stuff
with templates and jiggery-pokery enable
if and then all I forgot to go to the
not enable if version and which one will
get thing up all that stuff which is
possible but not very nice and it's
something that most application
programmers probably wouldn't want to do
when I try to get people to use
templates and we go yeah it's fine but
overload resolution control using this
it's it's not something where you really
want to go you go you feel like you're
kind of doing stuff in the language
rather than your application I think
with concepts you can now say this is my
application I can say this in a way that
actually is about my domain you can also
do some basic stuff here with things
like if Const expert and a concept name
so is lockable it would be a concept
here that says does this have lock and
unlock methods so I can say well if
you've got this if you have these
methods and I can check at compile time
notice that's a
I'll time check let go if you got this
one here you can call that great it
allows you to be able to do this a kind
of introspection in a way that you can't
do now because does this compile or not
I'm not quite sure where this quote came
from but it's useful anyway we want more
meta programming and less template
metaprogramming yeah we want to be able
to do this kind of stuff of you know I
can I do this based on this one I want
to do some special thing here but I
don't have to do the angle bracket e
thing yeah it's just kind of horrible
you're nasty with the recursive
templates and then yeah
it's it's something that you coming it's
a rabbit hole you go down and you
probably don't want to do it a lot of
application developers don't want to do
it because they don't see it actually
giving them an advantage
so the requires keyword is a way of
saying can this happen we've now got
this language based approach so doing
things so if you kind of look at the
history of where we've gone with this
one they started off with ways of trying
to do template overload resolution
control with things like the size of
trick if you are old enough to remember
that it was a really horrible thing
where where you had functions and it
returned a something of size one or size
2 and you looked at the size of and used
a dot dots as a final thing to to do all
the other cases yuck it was a horrible
enable if it was kind of a better
approach this one using finais they're
worth there's things in the experimental
library of ease detected the detection
idiom Walter Brown and the like that's a
kind of along the way but concepts
actually make this usable so we can
start to do overload resolution that we
couldn't do before so you now use this
as a design approach in a clean language
support rather than library hacks so it
gives us new stuff some basic stuff so
actually pieces of code yep let's have a
look at the simplest possible concepts
I've got a concept anything equals true
that says yeah this match is anything
that's the equivalent of type name T
I've got concept nothing that says now
you can't put anything in this you're
always going to be wrong so I've got a
one end yeah I can do everything the
other end then I could do nothing and
I've then got a kind of range of
possibilities in
it's up to you to decide what you want
so you've got a range of those things we
can do some stuff with inheritance as
well so actually you can override this
one's all specialize them but it doesn't
require the underlying type to be
changed this is one of the key things
about concepts is you don't have to go
and hack your underlying types to change
them to make them fit it's one of key
things about templates I don't have to
go and edit the class of int to make it
inherit from I disposable or whatever
you choose you don't doesn't generate
any code it's purely compiled time so
this is a very lightweight thing inside
the language inside the compiler you
don't have to do any extra stuff and we
can specialize it so we might have
something like try lockable saying well
okay this try lockable thing is well
it's lockable and it also has this try
lock part so we can now specialize this
we can now start having hierarchies and
we can actually base our system upon
well if you can match this if you can
match that if you can match that you can
get the compiler to pick the right thing
if you've got instead of having
hierarchies of object-oriented stuff you
can now use hierarchies of concepts and
use the compiler to do some work there
okay here's a fun little diagram it's
important diagram in many ways so the
two blue things on the Left type and
class those are closely related they're
tightly coupled and they're to do with
the way the languages is done so when
you create a class it has one or more
types now why do I say one or more
because of polymorphism if I have some
inheritance I have a base class in the
drive class the derived class can be
treated like a base class or a derived
class so it can be treated like two in
that particular case so it has multiple
ones on each type can be implemented in
multiple ways that's why it's many to
many but that is something you have no
control over really that's built into
the compiler built into the language
it's tightly coupled and if you go and
change one you're going to end up
changing the other now let's look at the
other side we have concept concepts in
some ways are completely
related to this you're going well okay
concept is a constraint on a type yeah I
can do that I can add it I can take it
away I can do it and notice I don't have
to change the type in any way if I use
two object-oriented inheritance I'd have
to go and edit the type or the class I
don't want this I can go yes one of
those does it match these this spec yes
or no it's loose coupling and so this is
really this side of the diagram is what
you as the developers get to play with
that type and class stuff is stuff
that's already built into language you
don't get to change and it is hardwired
into the language so that's why we have
this looser flexibility with concepts
they're also kind of giving you a form
of type erasure what do I mean by type
erasure type array Joe says I'm gonna
ignore some of the information about a
class or type because it's not
interesting to me right now it's a form
of abstraction we're used to doing this
in many ways interface inheritance with
a virtual function it goes I don't care
what class you are I care that you are a
pointer or a reference to this interface
and then when I call you you'll do
whatever the right thing is yes
essentially you've removed that
information about the actual class of
the thing in-game saying I don't care as
long as you have this method and I can
call it it's a form of titration but
where there are other forms of type or
Asia operator round brackets I just call
this thing is it a lambda is that a
function is it a function object we
don't know and the answer is we don't
care because at this point we're saying
look I don't care about the type I care
about what you can do see out of X yeah
whatever whatever that X is I don't care
it doesn't know how to print yank okay
go ahead print an iterator you go star
you go plus plus on an iterator you got
whatever I don't care
iterators are fantastic abstraction in
that sense concepts are similar to kind
of type erasure they give you a former
type erasure they go look I don't care
what you are I don't care where you come
from I don't care your parents I don't
care what anything about you what you
so ever other than what you can do it's
very democratic in that way so with
concept you're saying look I don't care
about this one with virtual functions
what you're doing is saying I create
this virtual I create my abstract
interface right okay now I have to go
and edit my types so that you can the
compiler can treat all these different
types together as that one thing so that
we can do the type erasure so they can
be where you put back together so the
compiler is happy and then at runtime I
have to kind of go and call the virtual
function get the virtual pointer and go
and do some mechanism to get back the
type that we originally had that I try
to get rid of so the compiler would talk
to it this seems like an awful lot of
work to have to go and edit something to
create this thing go and edit the class
then and just so the compiler is happy
and then recover it at runtime when you
discuss it like that you go yeah that's
kind of not very good if I were to do
this with concepts I go yeah have you
got these methods yeah you're one of
those great call it that's simple no
overhead I can even inline the call
great so we're now very much more
focusing on what the code does what it's
about we don't have to go into all these
procedural surgery right other important
diagram number two so the top part of
this one is where we are with
object-oriented stuff you go well I have
an interface here so essentially you
might think of Tyne going left to right
when you have a client and server with
an abstract with an interface or pure
virtual functions both the client and
the interface depend on me
sorry plant and server depend on the
interface you have to have the interface
available in order to compile
yeah you can't compile the client if it
needs to call an interface and it
doesn't know what it is so you have to
have interface dot H included there so
what you get from this though is
independent compilation because you can
go look that client there if it's trying
to call something in pass a string whoa
what where it wants an int the answer is
no conduct because you can compile them
independently if I try to read an
integer but a string was passed in the
server it goes no can't do so I get
independent compilation but notice
I can only put together those things
which are planned to go together it's a
white list it is you have to have
foresight to do this or you have to go
and edit the classes to make it happen
if you try to take some third-party
class and make it conform to this one
you either have to edit the class or do
some form of adapter pattern correct
that was what I mean
thank you John on the lower section
we're going to look at templates ignore
the green concept for the moment but if
you just look at the blue boxes you've
got X and then I have some some template
V that takes this one only put them
together notice that we have a different
dependency diagram because the first one
we have both of them depend upon having
that interface around because they can
be compiled they have to compile against
it in this one you go we'll look and now
the template and the thing that you're
putting into the template how are
completely unconnected so I can take
those that and that and put them
together and then say here when I
instantiate the thing on the right V of
X does that work yes or no this is why
generic programming is very powerful and
this is why the STL works because you
can have vector of int because inter
knows nothing about vector you don't
have to change a vector in any way if
you look at Java they're vector and
their collection ones have to be
java.lang integer they have to be a
boxed thing they have that you can't
take primitives and put them in because
it has to be something that derives from
something that will do that so that's
where the blue stuff comes from but we
don't get we don't get the independent
compilation because you can only go look
when I instantiate this and I put those
things together that's the Aero novel
thing again okay because I can't do it
independently and this is also you can
see why templates are checked in two
phases because they go what I can do the
bottom one yeah I can do this one I can
do all the non dependent names but until
you tell me what the T is I can't work
out
whether it's going to compile this
that's the 2-step compilation for
templates with concepts you go right
essentially I'm applying what looks like
an object-oriented a stew templates in
terms of requirements says yeah that
thing there I'm going to constrain the
type you can put in so my concept see
and go instead of having V of T it's V
of concept if I try to put that in he
goes nope you can't do that so what
we've ended up with is kind of the best
bit of this of the OO part of saying
yeah I can constrain it rather than just
being T and getting horrible errant
messages well along with this
independence of not having to know about
each other and not having to go and edit
stuff and getting a generousity so we
actually got the best of both worlds in
some ways here ok so maybe we're moving
in them in the direction of object
orientation oh wow it's been around a
long time
simulus 67 norwegian invention about 52
years old it's been around a long time
one of the classic oo books 1995 was the
Gang of Four book strong gamma Johnson
Helmand viscid s that's been around
that's a good long time too that's been
around 24 25 years there are lots of
patents in there so you'd recognize the
names a command observe a header ater
strategy and all the bits and pieces of
those ones you know what
most of those are concepts because most
of the stuff in the Gang of Four just
says let's introduce an interface they
go yeah well we want to do this stuff so
instead of having this problem with just
introduced an interface and they named
that interface so one of the things we
learned from the Gang of Four is that
names and vocabulary are very important
because these days we just talked about
observer pattern every goes yeah I don't
know what you mean rather than going oh
here's a box and this thing you never
heritance blah blah blah and have to
draw it out again it's a it's a chunk a
mean that we can use but those memes and
names are essentially can be mapped very
easily to see purpose concepts
but we can now do all that stuff before
with required us to have lots of object
oriented faces and inheriting from
things and virtual functions we can now
do the same kind of thing go look it's a
concept but by the way can I just take
this template put that together with
this concept oh look I can do virtual
eyes this code because I don't have to
add an interface so don't have to add
interface I don't have to go and change
my classes I can put them together
because it's just this calling that and
there's an at compile time you can work
that out rather than at runtime and
therefore can do things like in lining
the networking ts which is coming up has
got lots of these kind of names
completion handler things like executor
they're all concepts so the interfaces
that we often think about actually come
at very strongly to concept this is why
I think people that say all concepts are
hard they're maths and you should not do
anything else I'm missing out on this
big trick this is actually where I think
really is going to we're going to learn
about this one so name the application
level concepts are really important
let's not think about them as technical
or syntactic things okay let's since
we're in the world of our let's have a
look at some stuff around role modeling
so the picture on the left hand side is
if you ask people yeah I need to have
some stuff here I need a system for
Hospital also it has doctors and nurses
and patients usually the first thing
people come up with oh here's a person
I'm gonna have doctor and nurse and
patient as subclasses of person there
you go ok that sort of kind of works and
then I usually ask the question what
happens when the doctor gets ill mm
unfortunately what happens when the
doctor gets ill in this system is that
you have to you have to clone the doctor
well you have to create a person and a
patient from the doctor kill the doctor
and then when the patient gets better
recreate the doctor and come back again
because this these interfaces all these
types are hardwired in for the whole
life of the object you can't change them
it's not dynamic in any way and we can
go through various things about this one
here and the picture in the middle you
go well ok now I get a person here
and person has all the functionality
they may or may not have and then I'll
have interfaces instead so I'll have an
interface for a doctor and one for
patients so I can treat this person like
a doctor and then later if they get ill
I'll treat them like a patient as well
yeh we can do stuff with dynamic stuff
and things well okay and dynamic casts
and have you got this interface or not
but these are these are roles notice I
have to go on if I add a new one I have
to go on if I have some other thing like
visitor or whatever or some hospital
administrator or whatever I have to go
and create the new interface I have to
go edit the code and maybe it works
maybe it doesn't in the case of concepts
I go it's person right okay here's what
I need a doctor to do here are the few
things right can you do that great
you're a doctor I'll just treat you like
that oh I've got this other new role I
don't know II didn't can you behave like
that ok fine done I don't have to go and
create the interface I don't have to go
and edit the underlying class I don't
have to do all this work and I can do it
all compile-time this is why I think
it's something for application
developers to look at rather than
leaving this an isolated mathematical
thing okay enough of the bashing on
about oh let's have a little look at
some syntax so here is the syntax for a
concept basic stuff here templates like
90 so they're all templated totally
ordered requires an A in a B and you go
well look I want to be able to say that
a less than B must return a boolean or
something convertible to boolean I could
then add all the other ones about a
greater than B but what I can't do is
put a static assert in here than says
that a less than a isn't is never true
so that's part of our syntax of this one
we can only do syntactic checking axioms
you can't check anyway so how when you
specify that that end must be reachable
for begin when I give you in iterative
it's it's not checkable at all so you
are gonna need multiple things this
solves some problems it helps you with
the syntax it does not help you with
semantics and it does not help you
with axioms you are gonna need
documentation it is not a complete
solution but it's a damn good start
what can you check well what you're
checking really is doesn't with this
piece of stuff compile so here's a
little trap you can fall into right so
would this compile what is that you're
actually testing so on the Left I've got
concept food requires size of t equals
four
okay that's probably what you're
thinking yeah I do that one like a
static assert foo of int well in teaser
size four yes foo of char char is not
size four but that still passes hmm well
actually what you're doing here is
you're saying is size of fort in size of
t equals equals false in tactically
correct you're not actually checking the
thing if you really want to check that
condition you actually put requires size
of t equals 4 which is what on the right
hand side and there you can see
laureen's it's true but blair of char is
not so you're checking syntax if you
actually want to check return values you
need to do something else and you need
this nested require so there's just one
or two little corners and some fun
things that come up just some variations
on syntax so this is a little bit of a
history lesson here so you can start off
and going well the top we've got
template type name t f takes of t's
unconstrained you can put anything there
I don't care so that's the the basic one
I have a concept foo simplest one could
be true doesn't particular for this one
my options I can say template tag line
and type name T requires foo of T
requires that this thing must be true so
I can constrain the template argument
directly there so that's middle one
that's one way of writing a concept you
can then move to the next one says
template foo of T that moves the name
inside and it says right instead of type
name I'm saying which is generic and
everything this is this thing here so
you've now got a
much tighter way of writing it's one of
those I could say template input
iterator T or something along those
lines the TS the concepts TS then had an
abbreviated form which was controversial
and not adopted so we have void F foo
just pass a foo indirectly and you look
at that and go oh that looks very short
I quite like that I quite like that but
there are some problems with this one
one of the problems is it's a templated
function but you can't see it's a
templated function and there are
differences between templated functions
and non templated functions and so it
was like Oh grumble grumble grumble lots
of people didn't like it
the killer argument was if I do food ref
ref if foo is just an ordinary type that
then maps to an R value reference if foo
is concept that then is a forwarding or
universal reference and maps to our
values or L values and you can't tell by
looking at it so I mean okay fine
right though the syntax that was came
out was this constrained auto takes a
foo Auto something like that so putting
the keyword in auto in there but then
saying putting con the concept in front
saying it's Auto but constrained to this
and that's actually very generic and
general we'll see some other uses of
that concepts can be variables they can
also be functions so on the Left I've
got something here which is concept
container and requires the following
bits and pieces that says oh you have to
have a value type inside there you have
to have a nested iterator you have to
begin that returns an iterator notice by
the way you don't have to say type name
T Colin Cowie traitor here because type
lame has been removed in odd of 20 good
and you'll find that a vector means that
on the right hand side we have the
function version of this one here so you
can do those template variables
alternate functions fairly simulates a
syntactic difference but you'll need
parentheses on the other one just so
that you've got both right you can
combine these things you can combine
concepts with
functions and disjunctions with and and
all so I can say right I have a concept
integral is the standard integral stuff
I can have to say it's unsigned which is
unsigned of that and now I can say write
concept unsigned int is it's an integral
and it's unsigned so I can combine those
things and now you'll see that unsigned
int is definitely one of those and an
int is not an unsigned int and I can do
static checks and Static asserts and
notice it's checked at compile time
that's conjunction everybody goes yeah
that's great I can do that one another
thing you can do is a disjunction which
is causes certain amount of controversy
but I'm going to show you anyway because
I think there's some uses for this what
happens if I'm trying to write a library
for saving things for doing archiving of
stuff well I've got some stuff I got
some classes that have a save method and
some have a dumped method well I could
try and write one method that would do
this one and do the type stuff and put
some other things or I could write the
library and put adapters in front of it
there are various options here but maybe
what I can just do is go well look
archivable says you've got a save method
or you've got a dump method and then I
can go right okay this a switch has got
say V is archivable and the other one is
as well because it's one or the other
that's actually quite simple the other
ways of doing this with adaptors and
everything else look like there's a lot
of mechanism this actually kind of says
what I want well I want that one I want
that all that and to me I don't think
that's unusual it's actually something
you can't do with oo because with oh
well you go well I can't have an
interface yeah I can drive from one of
those or one of those
there's no all in object-oriented
inheritance so I can now so the stuff on
the left is just repeated from previous
slide the stuff on the right there you
go
archive well if you have a save method
call this one or I could say if you have
a dump method call this one so I can now
override based upon those concepts which
is kind of nice and that's why it's
Const path save auto because this is a
constrained
parameter archive 2 says well actually
look no I'm not going to do you the can
get the compiler to do this one I'm
going to be able to say I'll just have
archivable inside I can do if Const X /
I can do a runtime I can do a compile
time check and it goes yeah I could do
that one here
if it's a verb we'll call the save
method otherwise called dump and notice
that that can be inlined is compile time
I don't have an if statement so I've
eliminated that overhead so is a way of
avoiding things like adapter pattern
okay you've got existing code you're not
about to write all new stuff what do you
do with some existing code how do you
introduce concepts to an existing code
and there are some considerations you go
well okay first of all no bare T if it
says type name T you're going like well
what do you actually mean do you really
mean T or do you mean something else do
you mean it's got yep T but there's
obviously some requirements so let's
work out what that might mean what what
are you doing there past the main
parameters rather than integers as an
example but you can take an outside-in
or an inside out view so the outside in
views he's a domain base for you going
what are we doing here in terms of
abstractions what's what's generic
what's this really about if I look from
outside and don't worry about the
implementation what what kind of things
are we talking about so you can start
producing the main level concepts the
alternative approach is well you have
your head inside the box and go well
look I need to be able to call this and
that okay I'll just have the
requirements that it does this and that
so you take the implementation and you
push it outwards that works but again
you're lacking abstraction when you do
that you you end up with a minimal
syntax only based one rather than any
form of generic concept and this then
leads us to another parallel with our oh
we're cheese in object-oriented patterns
there are patterns you use for design
and some you sort of kind of discover as
you refactoring some of the design ones
you go well look I'm going to design
with this if I'm using composite pattern
it's usually because I'm going to design
with composite pattern right from the
start
that's kind
how I build my system observer can be
another example of that one and you go
well I have broad constraints here as a
broad concept in multiple constraints
they represent something in the domain
and they have an obvious meaning if they
don't have an obvious meaning then then
really you need to work out what it is
that you're actually trying to do but
then you might also have concepts that
you've discovered in a more so a kind of
technical wave through refactoring you
go well okay I've refactor this thing
out here and it's a very narrow concept
in the way that adapter pattern is sort
of kind of something that you don't want
to build your whole system out of
adapters it ends up is just so kind of
glue upon glue you know okay so that you
may well find the discovered ones what
happened when you take existing code and
add it
what about unit testing well you could
do unit testing and you put in it okay I
need to put in a virtual interface here
because I need to put use google mark
and I want to be able to have a
substitution point etc if I just use a
template with a concept that says all
right I need database here and it all it
needs is right all I need to do is just
provide something that has right it's
that simple it's documented what it is
well that's there is all I need to do I
don't need to I can break my
dependencies more easily I don't have to
go around and start using heavyweight
libraries and virtuals and all sorts of
the things I should just be able to just
go and do that okay one or two things
that about concepts that you can do with
concepts you can't really do with other
things this constrained auto so instead
of just saying Auto X I can go well look
it's some concept auto X if you because
if you're just using autos the return
type of a function it says Auto over
here you go Mike mmm what's that I've
got to kind of dig around you go well
yeah that's fine I whatever that is I
just want it to be able to do this stuff
because it becomes then I don't care
what the exact type is I just care what
it can do so you're now programming
terms of intention in terms of interface
and rather than in terms of type and
class
this disjunction of concepts is
something you can't really do without at
all because you can't do this multiple
inheritance well it could've a ball that
you can constrain non types so you could
actually have an implementation that
says well requires n less than ten
because this is the small object
optimization version of dr. if it's
bigger than that whatever hierarchical
constraints so there's a whole hierarchy
of things like iterators iterator types
you can actually have different concepts
for input it's right and forward
iterator and random access iterator and
have different functions called
depending on those you can't do that so
easily with our otherwise and other than
building all this stuff with inheritance
but then you've kind of lost all the
advantage of having just being to use a
pointer briefly there are some SI parla
score guidelines about concepts not
going to repeat them all but just to
point out that this is sort of kind of
the idea of no naked T so specify
template parameters as concepts use
standard concepts where possible that
doesn't protrude writing your own as I
said prefer concept names over Auto for
locals that like that one my concept and
prefer the shorthand notation for simple
ones so that's back to this guy here or
way back when the one at the bottom here
rather than the template one use that
simple shorthand one that's what that's
talking talking about in terms of
defining it don't just have concepts
without any form of meaning don't just
make them in terms of technical things
of it it has a operator plus nothing
kind of like that look for a complete
set of operations and constrain that
whole thing specify axioms even if you
can't put them there are other ones and
I'm not gonna go into the details you
can go and dig them out so summary they
are there to give you so concepts are
there to allow you to express the main
level concepts they are limited to
syntax and they limit what's coming in
they do not limp in an implementation
you should document your semantics and
axioms as well I think that these
make generic programming scalable and I
think they are a very useful alternative
to using oh oh and they make patterns
more efficient in terms of generic way
of doing this one here I think it's a
fundamental change in the way that we
write generic code and there are lots
more than just template error messages
okay any questions and yes I said now
are we if I remove Const from the
program that's correct
is it still correct yeah well the bottom
line where I'm making a serious point as
well I can get if I took away all the
Const if I took away all of the concepts
if I took away all the types and
assembler has no types at this point
right yeah probably because you've got
no overloading because what this is
doing is helping you to make it scalable
you know Python still works compiling
just does this at runtime essentially
because it's as well just I can take
anything it's type lengthy you need to
put it in
yeah and it's a runtime thing I'm
getting some I'm getting some of you so
there's a view here that maybe that
answer is is not without controversy
we'll have a chat later
any other questions yeah
yes it's not it's not a gimme in the
sense of yeah I can just do this and
throw concept everywhere yeah you're
gonna have to think about this but what
I'm trying to do is to is to get away
from this idea it's somehow this is this
sort of religious mathematical thing
that's real life that that's over in the
library and the standard and and
developers should just go yeah we'll use
that stuff no use it it's there for you
that's what I'm trying to say it's not
something that should be there should be
reserved for just a few people I think
it's much more much bigger than that
much more important than that but you're
right yes you it's not going to be just
kind of really to this one here and oh
oh interface because you've got
implementation that's hidden you're
gonna have all the overhead of moving
stuff into template files but then what
the modules do then mmm yeah there's we
can have some fun over the next few
years with this anybody else okay thank
you very much
[Applause]